[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[Каракурт,
Бессарабія]
«Вале е Гайдес» — це танець наших предків, можна сказати.
Ми живемо цими танцями.
Ми завжди готові виступати, якщо треба. Ми ніколи не відмовляємо, ми виступаємо.
[Анна Желяскова,
керівниця албанського культурного центру]
Душа палає. Я не знаю, як пояснити. Подобається нам це все.
Хоча ми — не професіонали, ми — аматори.
Ми любимо і намагаємось зробити все ідеально.
Албанські танці — помірні.
Якщо болгарські, молдовські — вони темпераментні,
албанські — ні.
[Юлія Караянева,
хореографиня]
Знаєте, кажуть:
«О! Албанці — народ з гір».
На Бессарабії це єдиний, та й взагалі в Україні, албанський колектив.
Це найперші наші костюми.
Ну і ми думали:
«Давайте вже назвемо колектив. Яку ж йому дати назву?»
— «Ріліндія»!
— А що це означає?
— Відродження.
— О! Це прекрасно!
І ось наші перші костюми.
Ми наш район називаємо «маленькі Балкани»:
і музика, і кухня дуже схожі на балканську.
У нас є такий, як кажуть, привілей,
мати дві батьківщини: і Албанію, і Україну.
І яку я люблю більше, я не можу сказати.
[Родіон Пандарь,
голова албанського товариства «Ріліндія»]
Вони для мене рівні.
Мені дуже подобалась мова. Завжди.
І під впливом подій 2014 року
у мені прокинувся такий національний підйом,
і я почав читати книжки: Кобзаря, Сковороду, Лесю Українку.
Більш за все мені подобалася Ліна Костенко.
І, читаючи вірші, я потроху почав розмовляти.
Спочатку — із сусідами.
Ну треба ж подолати бар'єр. Це найстрашніше  — подолати мовний бар'єр.
Потім немає вже ніяких проблем.
Збираються усі сусіди, товарищі
і по черзі ходять із вівцями,
щоб не тримати вдома.
Ну, наприклад, мені випадає [чабанувати] раз на місяць.
Я теж ходжу з вівцями.
Нічого страшного.
Дуже приємно на природі побути.
Поспілкуватися з вівцями.
Мій дід чабаном працював у колгоспі,
і від нього це перейшло до мене.
Я бачив, як треба годувати овець,
як їх треба стригти по весні.
Це для мене не важко — тримати овець.
Є чабани, які мають собак, і вони дуже гарно працюють,
тобто вони повертають овець.
Це Есмеральда, кішка. Вона теж хоче дати інтерв'ю.
Алло! Васю, ми виїжджаємо. Підходьте до Будинку культури.
Давай! Збирайте всіх.
[Осередки албанців в Україні]
Це Каракурт. Нашому селу більше двухсот років,
засноване у 1811 році вихідцями з півдня Албанії.
Але тут проживають і болгари, і гагаузи.
Більшість населення володіє всіма трьома мовами.
А зараз ми вже спілкуємось і державною мовою — українською.
У нас раніше не було українських шкіл.
Мені довелося самому вивчати українську мову.
Ну, хочу сказати велике спасибі Софії Ротару,
яка дуже красиво співає українські пісні.
Це для мене як вчителька.
Дмитре, давай вставай!
Все! Пішли за мною.
Васю, давай швидше!
15 хвилин і ми повинні бути перевдягнені.
— 15 хвилин?
— Так.
Може бути, що в тому.
Сьогодні у нас зустріч із двома викладачками з Албанії,
вони приїхали до нас.
Сьогодні будуть викладати сучасну албанську мову.
Не таку, як у нас тут розмовляють.
Це дуже цікаво для мене,
коли є можливість поспілкуватись із носіями мови.
І ми дуже вдячні державі Україна,
що завдяки її законам,
у нас є можливість поновити свою етнічну приналежність,
щоб ми знали хто ми, що ми, для чого ми.
[албанською] Добрий день!
[албанською] Ласкаво просимо! Раді зустрічі з вами!
Ця албанська мова — розмовна, побутова, вона дуже схожа.
А мову, яку вивчають уже в школі  —
літературну мову, особливо науковий стиль мови —
це взагалі нам незнайомо.
[Наталія Кірчева,
вчителька]
Тут мені вже дуже складно, оскільки тут уже іде повна самоосвіта.
Я вважаю, що я просто віддала належне нашим пращурам,
які змушені були бігти з рідних місць.
А я повернулась туди, щоб відродити мову, яку ми вже втрачаємо.
На початку 90-х років
у людей з'явилося бажання зрозуміти, хто вони такі.
У наших пращурів був важкий шлях:
протягом чотирьохсот років вони кочували, можна так сказати,
тобто вони переселялись із місця на місце,
але все одно свою мову вони зберегли.
І зараз розвивається ця культура, відроджується у нас,
Ми починаємо танцювати, співати,
ставити вистави, відтворювати обряди.
Також було бажання створити дитячий колектив у школі.
На нас хочуть дивитись,
тому що ми одні тут такі в Одеській області, в Україні.
[Православні албанці, втікаючи від гніту Османської імперії,]
[мігрували з Балкан на територію сучасної України на початку ХІХст.]
[Живучи поряд із українцями, болгарами, гагаузами, молдованами та румунами,]
[українські албанці переймали їх культуру та поширювали свою мову.]
[Власну ж культуру вони отримали змогу відроджувати після здобуття Україною незалежності]
[Чимало українських албанців стали жертвами Голодоморів, організованих радянською владою.]
[У 1932-33 роках у селі Дівнинське на Приазов'ї загинуло приблизно 500 албанців,]
[а у 1946-47 роках численні жертви були також і на Бессарабії]
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Микола Носок]
[Режисерка монтажу
Марія Теребус]
[Субтитрувальниця
Оля Стулій]
[Музика Valle Jugu]
[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[Серія відео створена за підтримки Агентства США з міжнародного розвитку (USAID)]